TONIGHT.
SEE YOU TOMORROW, HANNITY IS
NEXT.
>> Sean: BLIND PSYCHOTIC RAGE.
THANK YOU, TUCKER.
MAJOR SIGNS OF PROGRESS THANK
GOD IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
COVID-19.
THE PRESIDENT’S BOLD ACTIONS ARE
WORKING TONIGHT AND WHAT THE MOB
AND THE MEDIA WILL NEVER TELL
YOU IS THIS, THE CHINESE,
EUROPEAN TRAVEL BAN, THE
QUARANTINES, THEY SAVED THIS
COUNTRY, YOUR FELLOW COUNTRYMEN
AND WOMEN UNTOLD AMOUNTS OF
SUFFERING.
A MASSIVE OF FEDERAL SUPPLIES,
EVERY STATE IS GETTING
EVERYTHING THAT THEY NEED IN
RECORD TIME.
THOUSANDS OF VENTILATORS HAVE
BEEN DISTRIBUTED AND WE HAVE
10,000 STILL PLUS TO SPARE.
WE NEED THEM, GODFREY VID WE DO.
ALONG WITH MILLIONS OF N95 MASKS
AND MILLIONS MORE MEDICAL GOWNS
AND GLOVES AND ALL THE OTHER
NECESSARY EQUIPMENT.
EVERY STATE IN NEED AND MOST
WERE NOT PREPARED.
THEY SHOULD’VE BEEN, BUT THEY
WEREN’T.
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF A MEDICAL
MOBILIZATION THAT WE HAVE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE IN HISTORY AND IT
HAS THANKFULLY BEEN A SUCCESS ON
A LOT OF LEVELS.
WE COULD ALWAYS LEARN TO DO
THINGS BETTER.
A MASSIVE AMOUNT OF FEDERAL AID
HAS GONE TO NEW YORK, THE
EPICENTER OF THE DISEASE.
IN THE HOSPITAL SHIP, THE
COMFORT, HE ORDERED THE ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS FOR NUMEROUS
OTHER EMERGENCY HOSPITALS, THE
LARGEST IN THE COUNTRY AT THE
JAVITS CENTER AND THEN THEY WERE
BOTH TURNED INTO COVID-19
PATIENTS WHERE THEY WOULD TAKE
THOSE INCOMING AND BOTH THOSE
HOSPITALS WERE STAFFED WITH
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES AFTER BEING
BILLED BY THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS.
MEMBERS OF THE MILITARY STEPPING
UP AS THEY ALWAYS DO FLAWLESSLY.
IN OVER 20,000 HOSPITAL BEDS
BUILT IN LESS THAN A MONTH AND
BECAUSE OF THE PRESIDENT’S
ORDERS, BOTH THE NAVY HOSPITAL,
THE EMERGENCY HOSPITAL, 3,000
BEDS AT THE JAVITS CENTER
STARTED TO ACCEPT COVID-19
PATIENTS.
THANKFULLY MOST OF THOSE HAVE
NOT BEEN NEEDED AND NOW WE ARE
SEEING THE SIGNS OF SERIOUS
IMPROVEMENT.
THE NET CHANGE IN
HOSPITALIZATIONS WAS UP OVER
1400 BUT DURING THE WEEKEND, THE
CASES DROPPED TO UNDER 100 AND
TODAY, JUST 118 NEW CASES.
THE NUMBERS OF CRITICAL CARE
ADMISSIONS ARE EVEN BETTER.
THE ICU PATIENTS DECREASED BY
42.
DEATH IN NEW YORK HAS DECLINED
BY THE SECOND DAY IN A ROW AND
REMEMBER, WE KEPT SAYING THAT IF
THE PATTERNS HOLD, YOU WILL SEE
A LEVELING OFF AND THEN THE
DECLINE AND THEN A PRECIPITOUS
DECLINE.
THAT WILL BE THE NEXT STEP WE
HOPE.
EVEN GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO
ADMITTING PRESIDENT TRUMP PLAYED
A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
POTENTIALLY FLATTENING THIS
CURVE TO SAVE LIVES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HE HAS BEEN GOOD IN
DELIVERING FOR NEW YORK.
YES.
AND HE HAS DELIVERED FOR
NEW YORK.
THE ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS, THE
NAVY SHIP COMFORT TO NEW YORK,
HE HAS DELIVERED FOR NEW YORK.
HE HAS.
>> Sean: AND STAFFED THEM AND
ALL THE VENTILATORS THEY DIDN’T
BUY, HE TAUGHT THEM IN THE
STATE.
OVER A 5,000 OF THEM TO START
AND DESPITE WHAT YOU ARE NOW
SOME IN THE MEDIA AND SOME OTHER
PEOPLE DESPITE THE HOPEFUL
EFFECTS ON THE GROUND, THERE WAS
A LEVEL OF FEAR, HYSTERIA, PANIC
AMONG MANY ON THE LEFT, THIS
FRANTIC ANXIETY DOESN’T HAVE TO
DO ANYTHING WITH CORONAVIRUS.
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH HOW WELL
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS HANDLED
THE NATIONAL CRISIS.
TODAY DURING A POWERFUL PRESS
CONFERENCE, PRESIDENT TRUMP
RIGHTFULLY TORE THEM TO SHREDS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE DID ALL OF THIS WORK, BUT
WHEN YOU READ THESE PHONY
STORIES, NO ONE ACKNOWLEDGES
THIS.
IT DOES HAVE TO BE ACKNOWLEDGED
FROM THE GREAT WORK THAT THESE
DOCTORS, NURSES, THE ARMY CORPS
OF ENGINEERS TEAM, ALL THESE
PEOPLE HAVE DONE THIS INCREDIBLE
JOB AND THEY SHOULDN’T BE
ABUSED.
I WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO SAY
THAT WE HAVE A VERY HONEST
PRESS.
AND THEY WOULD BE NOTHING I
WOULD BE MORE PROUD OF IF THE
PRESS WOULD WORK, AND I DON’T
MIND BEING CRITICIZED, BUT NOT
WHEN THEY’RE WRONG.
NOT WHEN PEOPLE HAVE DONE A
GREAT JOB.
ONE THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
ACTING PROTECTING AMERICANS FROM
A FUTURE PANDEMIC.
DEMOCRATS OBSESSED WITH
IMPEACHING THE PRESIDENT, THE
MOB AND THE MEDIA CHEERING ON
THEIR DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
IS CLEAR THAT MEDIA MOB IS WELL
OF LIARS.
THEY HAVE SMEARED, SLANDERED,
BESMIRCHED AS PRESIDENT FROM THE
DAY HE CAME DOWN THAT ESCALATOR
AT TRUMP TOWER WITH
MELANIA TRUMP.
THEY ARE PROPAGANDA OUTLETS,
STATE RUN TV FOR THE RADICAL
DEMOCRATIC EXTREME SOCIALIST
PARTY.
THEY SPREAD ENDLESS LIES,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, ONE AFTER
ANOTHER.
THEN THEY NEVER ADMIT THEY’RE
WRONG AND THEY JUST MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT SET OF LIES.
THEY ARE HATEFUL.
THIS IS A DESTRUCTIVE FORCE FOR
THE COUNTRY.
I’VE BEEN SAYING IT FOR THREE
YEARS.
THEY HAVE CONTEMPT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY
THINK THEY’RE SMARTER AND THEY
KNOW BETTER.
DONALD TRUMP’S SUCCESS IS THEIR
FAILURE AND BY EXTENSION, IF THE
PRESIDENT FAILS, CLEARLY THAT’S
WHAT THEY WANT.
DO THEY CARE ABOUT THE DAMAGE
THEY’RE CAUSING THE COUNTRY?
APPARENTLY NOT, AND THEY
CONTINUE TO CAUSE DAMAGE.
IT’S CLEAR THEY HAVE ALWAYS
WANTED TO DEFEAT DONALD TRUMP.
2016, WHAT DID THEY DO?
HELPED HILLARY AS MUCH AS THEY
COULD IGNORING HER CLEAR
VIOLATION OF THE ESPIONAGE ACT,
THE DELETED EMAILS, THEY IGNORED
HER OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE,
IGNORED HER UNVERIFIABLE NOW
DEBUNKED DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER
USED TO SPY ON A CANDIDATE AND
LATER PRESIDENT.
AND THEY IGNORED THE BIGGEST
ABUSE OF POWER, CORRUPTION
SCANDAL IN OUR HISTORY.
THEY ADVANCED ONE LIE AFTER
ANOTHER ALLY AFTER ANOTHER LIFE
AFTER A CONSPIRACY THEORY AND
LIED.
AND NOW THEY ARE IGNORING
QUID PRO QUO’S JOE’S MISCONDUCT
AND COVERING FOR ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER, WE ARE AGAINST
QUID PRO QUO BUT NOT JOE, NOT
GETTING THAT UNLESS YOU FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR.
INVESTIGATING MY ZERO EXPERIENCE
ON WHO IS GETTING PAID MILLIONS.
IT’S CLEAR.
WE UNDERSTAND, THEY HATE
DONALD TRUMP.
YOU LIKE DONALD TRUMP, THEY HATE
YOU.
THEY HATE ME, THEY HAD A LOT OF
US HERE ON FOX.
THEY HATE RUSSIAN MARK LIVE IN
AND OTHERS.
THE SAME BAD ACTORS THAT BROUGHT
YOU RUSSIA AND IMPEACH, AND
OTHER STILL LYING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SOMEHOW MUST BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR COVID-19.
THAT GARBAGE OF A NEWSPAPER JUST
PUBLISHED A HIT PIECE, HE COULD
HAVE SEEN WHAT WAS COMING BEHIND
TRUMP’S FAILURE ON THE VIRUS.
OKAY, BEFORE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" TRIES TO
REWRITE THEIR HISTORY, LET’S
REMEMBER CHINA DIDN’T PUBLICLY
IDENTIFY.
WE DID NOT AS A WORLD KNOW ABOUT
CORONAVIRUS UNTIL JANUARY 7TH
WHEN IT FIRST GOT A NAME.
THE FIRST CASE WAS JANUARY 21ST
DAYS LATER, TEN DAYS LATER, THE
FIRST CASE JANUARY 31ST, THE
PRESIDENT IMPLEMENTED THE TRAVEL
BAN.
THEN THE MANDATORY QUARANTINE
AND THEN SUBSEQUENT TRAVEL BANDS
DECLARING DECLARING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY.
THEY SAID HE WAS OVERREACTING.
THEY SAID HE WAS A RACIST, BIDEN
SAID HE WAS ACTING OUT OF
HYSTERICAL XENOPHOBIA AND
FEARMONGERING.
THAT NEWSPAPER
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," THEIR
HEADLINE "WHO SAYS IT’S NOT SAFE
TO TRAVEL TO CHINA?
"GREAT ADVICE FOR YOUR READERS
ADDING THAT THE CORONAVIRUS
TRAVEL BAN IS UNJUST AND IT
DOESN’T WORK ANYWAY.
WORKED AND THIS TIME EVEN THE
COUNTRY’S TOP SPECIALISTS ARE
PREDICTING A NATIONAL CRISIS.
NOW FOR EXAMPLE, THERE IS NO
BETTER OR MORE RENOWNED, MORE
RESPECTED DOCTOR ON THE ISSUE OF
PANDEMICS, A MAN THAT HAS SPENT
HIS ENTIRE LIFE SAVING LIVES
COMING UP WITH TREATMENT,
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI, THE COUNTRY’S
LEADING INFECTIOUS DISEASE
EXPERT AND HE HAS DEDICATED HIS
LIFE TO FIGHTING INFECTIOUS
DISEASES AND SAVING LIVES.
HE HAS SERVED UNDER SIX U.S.
PRESIDENTS.
THIS IS HIS LIFE’S CALLING IN
HIS LIFE’S WORK.
PERHAPS NO ONE IN THE WORLD
KNOWS MORE ABOUT INFECTIOUS
DISEASES THAN DR. FAUCI.
I’M ABOUT TO SHOW YOU THIS IS
NOT AN ATTACK ON DR. FAUCI.
NUMBER ONE, CHINA LIED TO THE
WORLD.
NUMBER TWO, THIS IS ABOUT
CONTEXT.
START ON JANUARY 20TH.
AT THE TIME, DR. FAUCI WASN’T
SURE OF THE DISEASE WHICH SPREAD
FROM PERSON TO PERSON, NOBODY
KNEW.
COVID-19 WAS NOT A MAJOR THREAT
TO THE PEOPLE OF THE U.S.
SAID THAT THERE IS NO CHANCE IN
THE WORLD THAT THE U.S. COULD
SHUT DOWN A MAJOR CITY LIKE
NEW YORK OR SAN FRANCISCO.
REEMPHASIZE CORONAVIRUS ISN’T
SOMETHING AMERICANS NEED TO
WORRY ABOUT.
JANUARY 31ST, THE DAY THE
PRESIDENT ENACTED THE TRAVEL
BAN, HE SAID WE STILL HAVE A LOW
RISK OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
FEBRUARY 17TH, HE CALLED THE
RISK MINUSCULE.
AS LATE AS MARCH 9TH, DR. FAUCI
SAID HEALTHY AMERICANS, AND
GENERALLY HEALTHY, YOU CAN GO ON
A CRUISE SHIP IF YOU’RE HEALTHY.
NOT AN ATTACK ON DR. FAUCI.
HE WAS MAKING DETERMINATIONS
BASED ON FACTS AS THEY WERE
UNFOLDING IN REAL TIME DOING HIS
BEST AS EVERYONE ELSE WAS.
BUT IT DOES SHED A BRIGHT LIGHT
ON THE PRESIDENT’S DECISION
EARLY ON TO BE CALLED A RACIST,
XENOPHOBIC, FEARMONGERING
ET CETERA TO PUT THE TRAVEL BAN
INTO EFFECT.
A FACT THAT DR. FAUCI CLARIFIED
TODAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP USED
DR. FAUCI’S EXPERTISE AS TO
IMPORTANT TOOLS TO MAKE CRITICAL
DECISIONS EVERY SINGLE STEP OF
THE WAY.
THEY CORROBORATED, THEY WORK
TOGETHER IN THE INTEREST OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WAS A PERFECT SCIENCE?
NO.
THESE THINGS NEVER ARE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE FIRST AND ONLY TIME THAT
DR. BIRX AND I WENT IN AND
INFORMALLY MADE A RECOMMENDATION
TO THE PRESIDENT TO ACTUALLY
HAVE A "SHUT DOWN" TO REALLY
HAVE STRONG MITIGATION, WE
DISCUSSED IT.
OBVIOUSLY, THEY WOULD BE
CONCERNS BY SOME AND THAT MIGHT
HAVE SOME NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES.
NONETHELESS, THE PRESIDENT
LISTEN TO THE RECOMMENDATION AND
WENT TO THE MITIGATION.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT RELIED
ON THE EXPERTS BUT EVEN IN SPITE
OF IT, NO ONE THOUGHT THE TRAVEL
BAN WAS NEEDED AT THAT TIME AND
HE WAS WIDELY CRITICIZED AND HIS
OWN OBSERVATIONS ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN CHINA, HIS OWN GUT
INSTINCT THE PRESIDENT HAD THE
FORESIGHT, THE COURAGE, THE
WISDOM TO DO SOMETHING NO OTHER
PRESIDENT HAS DONE AND OVER 50
YEARS IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE TRAVEL BAN OF QUARANTINES
PUBLIC-PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
REWRITING ALL OF THE BOOKS ON
HOW WE DEAL WITH PANDEMICS.
AND RIGHT OUR EYES WE ARE
WITNESSING A PARADIGM SHIFT.
IS SAVING UNTOLD AMERICAN LIVES.
HATE IS PREVENTING UNTOLD TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF OTHER AMERICANS
FROM CONTRACTING THE DISEASE,
EXTRAPOLATING OUT FROM THERE,
SAVING AMERICAN LIVES.
THE MEDIA MOB, THEY CONTINUE TO
LIVE.
IN FOCUS NOT ONLY ON BEATING THE
DISEASE BUT ALSO FIGURING OUT A
WAY TO REOPEN THE ECONOMY.
WE CAN’T GO ON LIKE THIS
FOREVER.
NOT ENOUGH MONEY, CAN’T PRINT
YOUR WAY OUT OF THIS MESS.
THIS WILL BE ESPECIALLY TRICKY
IN THOSE HIGH DENSITY POPULATION
AREAS.
FOR EXAMPLE, GOING TO BE A LOT
MORE CHALLENGING IN
NEW YORK CITY THAN ANY OTHER
PLACE.
MY POSITION, HALF THE WORKFORCE
IF YOU HAVE NONESSENTIAL
PERSONNEL, MANY AMERICANS IT
WILL BE A NEW NORMAL NOW TO WORK
FROM HOME AND NUMBERS NEVER
BEFORE SEEN.
PEOPLE GOING INTO WORK MIGHT
HAVE THEIR TEMPERATURE TAKEN.
MIGHT EVEN HAVE TO GET A
COVID-19 TEST.
SOCIAL DISTANCING WILL BE A PART
OF LESS CROWDED OFFICE SPACE.
ALL OF THAT, GLOVES, MASKS FOR
THE TIME BEING, THERE IS A
DISRUPTION IN EVERYBODY’S LIFE.
KEEP IN MIND OUR ECONOMY NEVER
FULLY CLOSED, TRUCKERS WERE
WORKING, FARMERS WERE WORKING MY
GROCERIES WERE WORKING,
MANUFACTURERS OF MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT AND VENTILATORS WERE
ALL WORKING HARD KEEP THE
COUNTRY SAFE, TAKE CARE OF OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS AND HOSPITALS
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THEIR SAFETY, THEIR WELL-BEING
SO CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
BUT SO TOO ARE OUR INALIENABLE
RIGHTS.
AS WE GO TO REOPEN BUSINESS IN
THE COUNTRY, WE CAN’T DENY CIVIL
LIBERTIES, CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS.
PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO MEDICAL
PRIVACY.
HE CAN’T BE TRACKING AMERICANS
AS THEY TRAVEL.
YOU CAN HAVE NATIONWIDE
DATABASES WITH AMERICA’S
PERSONAL HEALTH INFORMATION ON
IT.
I DON’T TRUST ANY OF THAT IN
WASHINGTON IN THE SWAMP.
CONSTITUTIONAL INFRINGEMENTS
COMING FROM SOME STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, THIS HAS TO STOP.
GREENVILLE, MISSISSIPPI,
HOWEVER, PEOPLE TICKETED $500
FOR ATTENDING A DRIVE THROUGH
CHURCH SERVICE.
DRIVE THROUGH.
SOCIALLY DISTANT CHURCH SERVICE.
ONE CALIFORNIA TOWN ISSUING AN
ORDER MANDATING MASTS WHENEVER
THEY LEAVE THEIR HOMES, ONE GUY
IN PENNSYLVANIA BECAUSE THEY HAD
TEN COPS.
MICHIGAN’S GOVERNOR BANNING ALL
GATHERINGS OF ANY SIZE INCLUDING
THE PURCHASE OF CERTAIN TYPES OF